bonjour florence gérard merci d'être
avec nous ce matin sur rtl france
alors le gouvernement at il pris les
mesures adéquates en ce qui concerne les
confinements des sdf et des migrants
alors aujourd'hui les personnes qui
étaient hébergés dans les différents
centres rang reste dans les différents
centres aux oeuvres de la mie de pain
nous avons mis en place des mesures de
protection à la fois de nos personnels
et puis les personnes qui sont à la rue
depuis maintenant dix jours les visites
sont interdites dans les centres de
sorte qu'ils aient moins de risques les
mesures barrières sont bien évidemment à
en place avec systématiquement accès aux
savons gels hydro alcooliques à l'entrée
et puis bien sûr nous demande de
respecter la distanciation social est à
un mètre de distance
maintenant c'est compliqué pour les
différentes personnes et c'est un
travail de pédagogie des équipes qui
sont qui sont présentes
alors on imagine que
les distributions de denrées
alimentaires vont être compliqués dans
les jours à venir
comment comptez vous vous organisez
justement sur ce plan dans la situation
est effectivement extrêmement compliqué
nous avons à essayer de maintenir autant
possible nos activités
bien sûr nos activités d'hébergement
mais aussi nos activités pour les
personnes de la rue il faut savoir qu
habituellement nous servons 260 repas à
des personnes de la rue qui viennent de
façon anonyme tous les tous les soirs
s'est servi par des bénévoles
nous en avons 300 régulièrement pour une
semaine actuellement nous sommes à
quelques dizaines nous avons donc dû
réorganiser cette activité et grâce au
professionnalisme à la mobilisation de
nos salariés nous arrivons à maintenir
ses repas extérieur simplement
distribuant des repas pique nique froid
et donc les personnes viennent les
chercher et elles partent avec néanmoins
on constate une forte baisse de la
distribution puisque le premier jour
lundi nous n'avons eu que 160 personnes
et hier soir il ya eu 120 personnes qui
se sont présentées
du fait des difficultés des sdf à
circuler des contrôles qu'il peut y
avoir certaines renonça à venir mais
d'autres a aussi peur et donc ne
viennent pas manger ce qui est une
difficulté et en dehors de l'alimentaire
pardon non je vous en prie a lésé
consciemment en dehors de l'alimentation
ce que nous avons maintenu également
pour les personnes de la rue c'est
l'accès à la propreté
nous avons dû fermer notre accueil de
jour c'est à dire qu'ils n'accueillent
plus de personnes à l'exception des
douches ans pour lequel on continue à
être ouvert et hier nous avons accueilli
une quarantaine de personnes qui peuvent
venir à se laver et pour qu'elle
continue à pouvoir laver leur linge que
nous faisons plus nous mêmes nous leur
distribuons des jetons pour aller dans
des laveries automatiques
là encore nous avons habituellement 120
douches par jour qui sont assurés vous
voyez que nous sommes aux tiers
il y à une question de circulation pour
les sdf
vous le disiez donc les centres
d'hébergement pour les personnes en
difficulté qui servent à se nourrir à
dormir à se laver est ce que ces
derniers jours
ces personnes en difficulté ont
justement été plus nombreuses à vous
sollicitez dans les associations et les
centres d'hébergement
alors les personnes que nous accueillons
sont elles-mêmes extrêmement inquiète
à l'instar de nos personnels ils sont
inquiets parce qu'ils vivent dans des
lieux collectifs ils sont eux-mêmes
vulnérables la collectivité les expose
davantage et pour ceux qui sont à la rue
la question c'est où aller on journée
est-ce que vous avez des des réponses de
la part des autorités peut-être du
gouvernement sur ce qu'il était prévu
pour justement ces centres d'hébergement
est pour vous le personnel qui y
travaille et alors nous avons entendu
l'annnonce de centre de desserrement à
hier c'est un point positif et il
faudrait qu'il se mette en route a
rapidement nous avons actuellement à la
mie de pain trois personnes qui ont les
symptômes du coronavirus une qui est
hospitalisée mais deux qui sont chambre
d'isolement à l'intérieur de notre
centre c'est un souci pour eux
poursuivre leur état de santé c'est un
souci pour les personnels également qui
s'inquiètent
la perspective de pouvoir les transférer
dans ce centre est une perspective
favorable et on souhaiterait qu'elle
intervienne rapidement de sorte que
toute personne qui a présentent des
symptômes puisse être sorti des cendres
et le risque pas de contaminer les
personnes hébergées et les personnels
qui sont là nous fonctionne avec des
personnels qui sont extrêmement dévoué
il faut vraiment leur rendre hommage et
je les remercie
ils sont inquiets ils ont des familles
certains sont eux mêmes personnes
vulnérables ans et un font l'effort de
venir nous avons actuellement un tiers
nos effectifs qui sont ligne directe
avec les personnes hébergées
il est très important de préserver la
santé de tout ce monde
merci
beaucoup florence gérard merci d'avoir
été avec nous ce matin je rappelle que
vous êtes le président de l'association
me paraît bravo pour ce que vous faites
vous êtes soucier en première ligne dans
cette lutte contre ce virus merci
beaucoup